Let's look at the solution to
our write-update coherence quiz.
Where what we had is
four accesses like this
happening in a write-update
coherent set of caches.
After the first read completes here,
we have data 6,
tag 700 hex, and the valid bit is one.
So when this read completes,
we have a valid with 1 here,
the data is 6 and the tag is 700.
At that time, in these other caches,
the valid bit is simply zero,
because they have not
accessed anything yet.
When core 1 reads, it sets the valid
bit and fetches the same data.
When core 2 writes, it broadcasts
the value in the address, so these
caches that already have this block
will update what they have now to 17.
And now, of course, on core 2,
this block starts being valid and
has a value of 17.
And finally, when core 3 reads,
it also gets the value of 17.
So, this is the final
state of the caches.
All caches have the block and all caches
have the same value of the block.
Which means that really the caches
are coherent for this block.